our number two of the Rich Eisen show is
on the area Brett Favre and our number
one triple cheese joining us in studio
our number three we're back from our
three-day weekend and I'm joined to my
right by one of my favorite people
favorite guests that we've had here on
this program and who knew as you know
good things brockman happened in threes
who knew that this man was the one that
started the great things happening with
threes that ended with Baker Mayfield in
calamari he's none other than Chris
Harrison good a weird sandwich you have
today Favre yes triple G triple G yeah
Chris Harrison where exactly do I fit in
that spectrum our two three-hour show
we're talking sports thanks for not just
saying he's number two no no your guess
number one of power
okay got it and in season 15 of The
Bachelorette
yeah which just launched we're not in
June yet so earlier this no yeah episode
two or were two episodes three episodes
in and this young lady Hannah brown yep
from University of Alabama Alabama the
pride of Alabama every single time your
show airs that gentleman Brockman comes
in is the best show on television and
saying that she's uh she's interesting
she's on roll tide one of the best parts
I had never been to Tuscaloosa and
obviously just to being a football and a
sports fan yes we'd like to go to Bama
okay I didn't get to go to a game but I
went and got to kind of partake all that
is Tuscaloosa
man it is roll tide through and through
it is that is there any chance that you
could get Nick Saban involved to finish
this season huh here's what I would love
and it's a possibility what I would like
is for Saban just to come on at the end
and just give her a pep talk
of first the final yeah like final rose
final rose ceremony were close she's not
sure Saban comes in and just chill gets
our fired up
well the guy the guy the guy normally
Chris talks about making sure that you
just ignore all the noise okay right
just focus
on the task at hand calls all the noise
the outside noise rat poison I don't
know if that wouldn't work
there's a lot of rat poison this season
you might that's you might have to tweak
his stump speech but maybe he gives it
to the guys I mean to save and probably
have like 5 speeches you know like he
says the go-to I know he's got one in
the top left drawer what's this it's
like a little like things like all right
situation like Bowl game yes
mid mid season we're in a slump yeah you
know we're gonna go and defeat it again
what's that how do I keep everybody
fired up chip-on-the-shoulder
my favorite speech is Saban's this is
usually what chris would you say it's
about late November it's mid November
they're undefeated undefeated and and
the the team that they've paid to come
play in Tuscaloosa directional school to
warm up for Auburn's coming in Northeast
Louisiana some directional our Lady of
the lake is coming it's coming in and he
he's just gonna make sure that all the
kids are not looking to the Iron Bowl
yeah that's my favorite 92 yeah and then
and then they're down 7 nothing first
quarter Twitter's blowing up and you
just know Saban's halftime speech the
paint is going to be peeled in some way
shape or form that's what I need for
Hannah
that's what I need for Hannah okay and
so you're 15 now is just you're you're
just on a roll this is me yeah you would
think I would think about 17 years of
this has definitely Garner's us to be
that legendary status of television
because it just doesn't happen I mean to
go this long between this many bachelors
this many bachelorettes it really is an
incredible run it is a dynasty the likes
of which you don't see in sports
I'll tell you what Chris last time you
were on you were getting ready to
officiate a wedding yeah during the
Cowboys Rams playoff game missed that we
made your conundrum for you the Cowboys
lost that game right turns out going to
Hawaii was not such a bad choice yeah
Ari and Lauren's wedding I
married them in Hawaii and I missed that
Cowboys game it's literally a stone's
throw from here right but yeah that was
that was that was a tough call but the
right choice to make but you had to do
that yeah it's the only one that you
have officiated to this point in time
correct no I've done I've done a handful
now Jaden Jaden Tanner Ashley and JP
I've done a bunch of these weddings yeah
mm laughter we've spawned children I
have children
does anybody jump the fence on you just
Colton huh
just Colton he's the one that's jump the
fence that's the only one I was at NFL
Films and then they asked me if you
could kind of compare you know Colton to
this you know someone in the NFL and I
said well I would say you take the
Lambeau leap you have a little bit of uh
you know Bo Jackson yes and Odell
Beckham yes like the artistry of Odell
Beckham with the athleticism of Bo
Jackson that was the leap have you ever
tried to Lambeau leap have you ever done
no but I tried the leap I tried Colton's
lead okay and and it took me three tries
because one thing is I went I went to
the tape I slow mode it down I went into
the film room the thing is that was so
athletic about it is once he lept up
know if that's correct but he never
touched the fence or the top of the
fence like he didn't drag the foot and
his foot never touched the top you know
you get your foot up and then you top
over it was floor floor that was this
like so vault yeah and so it took me a
minute pommel horse ish yeah it took me
a minute to get over the pommel horse
the way he did he does have about three
or four inches on me so by the way I
think that's the first time in armor
near five years of the show just because
every said pommel horse ish its Hummel
horse it's a verb we were pommel horsing
Chris Harrison here on the Rich Eisen
show all right what do you think Connor
Murray's gonna do to the next level here
but what do you think uh what do you
think he's I think he's gonna be
explosive he's gonna be exciting he's
gonna have growing pains I mean let's
not kid ourselves right he still got to
go from college football which moves at
this speed to pro football which moves
at a thousand miles an hour and all of a
sudden those guys aren't open anymore
but I will say this is gonna be
unbelievably exciting and like most
quarterbacks the RG threes of the
guys like that the VIX he'll extend
plays and they'll make things happen
that most guys wouldn't because of those
growing pains so I think he's gonna be a
little bit better just because he's he's
athletic he's all get-out and it's just
I can't wait to watch every single one
of these early games that he's gonna
have office that the first ones against
Detroit at home and then he it's him
versus Lamar Jackson you tell me you're
watchin Browns Detroit I am I am
watching as many of those as I possibly
can so I'm watching Cardinals versus
Your Honor I rest my case
know that right Browns Detroit is a game
on your calendar yes exactly is just one
well I love Baker Mayfield - you know I
love I love every last one of these
girls Baker is gonna be amazing watching
watching Baker Mayfield this year
watching Kyle Emery play this year watch
there's a lot of exciting story your guy
Jack would you pay him 30 million
Truscott yeah I think that's that's
what's going on with the Cowboys right
here's the issue when you talk about
franchise quarterbacks okay this is a
great example because a Kyler Marine
Baker Mayfield those are the best picks
you can get as of late in the draft
mm-hmm would you not say I'll take dak
Prescott over those guys
he's a franchise quarterback oh I I it's
his turn to get paid where are you gonna
go where else has he PP won he won a
playoff game for the Dallas Cowboys
which again you can count on the number
of one hander I hate talking about
quarterbacks since Troy and the triplets
laughing he's done that it's his turn to
get paid I mean look what they just did
to get caliber look what they did to
poor Josh Rosen right oh no I mean think
that's how valuable a franchise
quarterback is would you what would you
have made that play for for Kyler Murray
yeah if I switched my coach like that
bringing in a system for which Murray is
perfect yeah
I would have I would have thought real
long and hard about it
I'm just a big Rosen fan yeah I'm a huge
Josh Rosen fan yeah did you see how you
straddle but no I understand why the
Cardinals did what they did like I said
I am watching Cardinals lines
I'm watching again it's gonna be Cuyler
Murray versus Lamar Jackson week - then
you're gonna see Carla Murray versus
Russell Wilson twice a year you're gonna
see you again seriously you're gonna be
watching the Cardinals and the Browns
play football this year that is correct
thanks to the Oklahoma Sooners really
thanks - oh you that's really a bizarre
they think of all the talent that's now
I mean I was with somebody I don't know
who it was because there's only one in
the world but I was ran into a Browns
fan and got to hear the excitement sorry
Cleveland had they been beaten enough I
know I really you know what if I wish
anybody well I would love to see the
Cardinals do well because they've been
bad for a while and your friend and mine
Larry Fitzgerald one of the best human
beings ever I wish him well and that's
why I think that's really where I am
yeah I'm a Cowboys fan but I I meet
these players I love Larry Fitzgerald he
is as good a human being and I wish that
I hope 'tyler comes in and they can do
something special but wouldn't wouldn't
we all be a little excited if the Browns
were good oh my gosh if they mean how
that makes the NFL like your font I
agree with you the biggest NFL fan of
your shows are is who that you've come
across pitch jolt is a big one hmm I
mean if I go back you know God rest his
soul
Dwight Clark no kidding one of the best
stories ever had I was sitting at I
think it was back in it was Drew Brees
his golf tournament down in San Diego no
yes sitting in a bar and this guy came
up to me and I wasn't really paying
attention he's like hey you Chris
Harrison I said yeah how you doing he's
like Dwight Clark I said you son of a
[ __ ]
and he goes Cowboys fan I said yes sir
and he said can I buy you a beer
I said come on that's the least you can
do for ruining my childhood and Dwight
and I actually formed a friendship and
we talked and we kept kept in touch for
many many years an odd friendship and he
actually signed a ball for me exa note
the play the catch yes as kind of like
in a special fu to me and ruining my
childhood that Dwight Clark gave me that
but a great guy and in a big bachelor
fan big bad fan don't know and how about
what Jesse Palmer's turned her into
right now right I mean none that he has
really taken that platform and run
literally
with it yeah it's been amazing are
better than his NFL career the Giants
you know what's interesting in with
Jesse Palmer he came in I said why are
you doing this like really why are you
doing this and he goes well he's like
yeah what I love to find somebody sure
he's like but my agent said this might
be a good platform and a good launch to
start a sports casting career and I said
buddy I said no one's ever really
launched anything from this I I don't
know if that's such a great idea
yeah well well you're the kind of
reverse of that right sports casting
career I was casting into the network I
never saw that Chiron dunder your face
Network someone said one time like you
know if you have a card you don't can I
have your number do you have a card is
it if I did have a business card which I
don't what would it say what everything
no network pimp I think that would be at
work pimp yeah
before we concluded this latest visit to
this show and I always love having you
here Chris Harrison you've got a new pod
out yeah with none other than the great
Hall of Famer Johnny Miller Johnny
Miller yeah so this is awesome you know
again you mentioned I used to be a
sportscaster my love is sports and I
could talk it all day I have this
friendship as you do you with Callaway
and they called and said you know we
need a host someone who loves golf
passionate who but can also really hang
and push Johnny Miller because he wants
to get back on the mic he still has
stuff to say and and honestly you're
watching the PGA Championship and Brooks
koepka goes bogey bogey bogey bogey 11
through 14 I wish I knew what Johnny
Miller was saying right then right and
you know what's he saying about John
Daly Nick Carter Phil Mickelson going to
Pebble Beach and so we decided let's put
Johnny Miller back on the mic and so he
and I are doing a series of six podcasts
it's on now you can go to Callaway calm
or we're now on iTunes it's real golf
talk with Johnny Miller hosted by me hmm
and it's just the world according to
Johnny and I'm asking him about Tiger
about Brooks koepka about Phil Mickelson
is he ever gonna win the US Open what
did you say about sleeping on the lead
with seven shots and when John Daly he
was great I'll give you a little spoiler
I said you know what do you think of
John Daly's is maybe he should have been
home watching soap operas and we all
need to know when it's time to hang it
up and maybe he needs to know it's time
to
it's been a long time since he had a an
F to give Johnny here's the thing he's
run I mean literally he ran out of them
decades you're kind of a sports guy yes
thank you
name me a sport mm-hmm any other sport
in the world where you're hurt
mm-hm and so the entire game has changed
for you hmm
that the game is you mean the entire
Santa rameters of the example Kevin
Durant is hurt yes I'm sure they would
love to have him out there how about you
have to stand three feet away from Kevin
Durant he gets to shoot right you can't
touch him and you can't put your arm up
right that seems fair I mean he's hurt
try or you move the three-point line in
or something tom brady's has hurt has
hurt put a red jersey on him you cannot
touch Tom Brady he gets one throw or 10
seconds before anyone can rush him right
yeah but that's kind of the rule anyway
[Music]
so much changed then then golf it just
seems odd and they're you know they're
they're they're trying to get it he got
it for the Senior Tour and they're
actually talking to the RNA about the
British Open right and I my hope is that
the the RNA is strong and bold enough
and has enough respect for their sport
that they're like please yeah I know I
I'm walking as part of this really was
strange it was you know we sitting there
with with smoking heaters and he's got
his McDonald's Cup and I'm like really I
don't know I use you were not loving it
I did not love that you're not loving it
all right you get sour the Rich Eisen
show brought to you by pain out corner
over there before we send Chris out
there you you got questions about Hannah
I know that you're you're you are truly
the most die-hard Bachelorette I'm and
I'm into this show a lot the guys have
been fascinating
Luke P to me this yeah Luke P what's his
story
what about ABC always be cam now this
guy is he doing a bit is that is this a
I hope so for his sake I hope so
it has to be right so cam obviously I
won't give any spoilers but I think
you'll see what happens to camp soon but
Luke P here's the thing you know you
talk about villains it really has to do
with
how the bachelor/bachelorette feels
about that person of how big of an
impact they'll have and she obviously
cares for Luke P although she did put
him in his place last night she did well
there's no pity roses right I mean
that's what she's saying she's not
handing out any pity but she stopped
what she was doing got up took him to
another room and was like yo bro like
check yourself this is what I love about
ya this is what I love about Hanna she
handles her own business she does she
wears her heart on her sleeve she is
emotional but man she will handle her
own business and I'm like all right I
mean years of being in the pageant game
I got it you're doing in the pageant
maybe honestly growing up in the shadow
of Nick Saban this is what needs to
happen n-c-double-a Bachelorette or
combination here yeah I think we need to
do this Lane Kiffin comes out somehow
some way just to spook right Sabin
last-second or I don't I'm just I'm
spitballing here right there's a lot of
roll tide references I'm just gonna
apologize to bachelor nation we get it
there's a lot of roll tide but if you're
ever in Tuscaloosa which I have been
that's it's just a way of life well I'm
why not yeah why not every every
November when I go through my what seems
to be an unfortunate ritual these days
for me with Ohio State and I go through
these cathartic first quarter 2nd
quarter moments where I'm staring at the
ceiling or or lacked last year just
throwing myself into the love of my
children playing with my kids on the
floor wondering why does this mean we're
we're like why does this as a grown man
with so many different outlets why does
this mean so much to me I just would
love to just for a split second be an
Alabama fan where you just don't have
those issues you don't have a care in
the world while we've been on the air
during this interview they've won four
national water skiing behind a few
yachts these days that's true I mean you
know things are pretty damn good for you
too at Chris B Harrison on both Twitter
and Instagram the Bachelorette on ABC
airing Mondays at 8:00 Eastern Time keep
an eye out for ro Nick Saban and also
that podcast viewed yeah real off talk
with Johnny Miller check it out with
death
it's actually really good I enjoyed it
by the way me enough to go higher
register and say actually really good
its you could say this is great
I love it I'm great I do love it okay it
is awesome you can say that it's okay
Chris Harrison here on the rich oyster
when we come back we'll show a clip of
the latest episode of The Bachelorette
that's coming up with Chris Brockman's
news update and also triple G's hanging
out in our green room we will wrestle
today that'll be great yeah that'll be
great you haven't had enough contact for
the day Chris Harrison here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app